a variant of coronavirus first
identified in india has today been
classified
as a variant of concern by the uk
government more than
500 cases of b16172
have now been detected across england
this is a sharp rise from the 202 cases
officially recorded by public health
england on the 28th of april but it is
still
a small proportion of overall cases
the indian variant has two key mutations
in its spike protein the first is called
l452r which has also been found
in a variant circulating in california
although the indian variant has evolved
independently
the second is called e484q
a completely new mutation lab tests
suggest
both help the virus to infect cells and
to evade
antibodies while it's still unknown what
real world effect
that would have on vaccines it's got all
the hallmarks
of a dangerous virus and phe today said
it's at least
as transmissible as the kent variant
well here's the situation with
coronavirus in the uk
at the moment low cases overall but
numbers higher
in places where we know the indian
variant has been located
the first cases were found in northern
ireland for example
the local government region of derry
city and strabane
both above the uk average with a 16
rise in cases over the last week
similarly bolton in the northwest is
also
seeing a spike in the week to the first
of may it had
a total of 241
cases that's a 75 rise
cases of the indian variant are thought
to be found in schools care homes
and places of worship largely linked to
travel
to the subcontinent and despite london
seeing fewer cases
it's still an area of public health
england has identified
as seeing a surge in cases of this
indian variant
phe says there is currently insufficient
evidence to indicate that
any of the indian variants cause more
severe disease or make vaccines
less effective but boris johnson did say
the government needs to think very
carefully
about the public health response